ايه ده مشاهدينا اهلا بكم في تفاعلكم رقص
مدرب ولاعبي البرازيل تفجر جدلا واسعا
احتفال ام قله احترام للخصم
والاتحاد الدولي للطيران يعلن تعافي
القطاع من تداعيات كورونا
والداخليا المصريه تكشف هويه الممرض في
فيديو الرهان المؤسف اهلا بكم
اذا مشاهدينا لعب امبارح الاثنين منتخب
البرازيل مع منتخب كوريا الجنوبيه في دور
ال16 في كاس العالم والبرازيل تاهلت الى
دور الثمانيه بفوزها باربعه اهداف مقابل
هدف واحد لكوريا البرازيل طبعا من اكبر
المرشحين لنيل اللقب هذه السنه وهو يعني
منتخب تاريخ وعراقب كره القدم موجوده في
ومش محتاجه لاثنين يحكوا فيها هذا غير انه
عندها خمس القاب تخيلوا خمس ارقام عالم
عمرها ما غابت اصلا عن كاس العالم وفي
مباراه امبارح يعني ممكن نقول انه لاعبين
البرازيل سيطروا على المباراه تماما
والاهداف الاربعه على فكره اجو في اول نصف
ساعه فقط من المباراه لكن عموما مش هذا هو
موضوع فوز البرازيل امبارح عمل ضجه حول لا
مش طبيعيه وسبب هو احتفال اللاعبين بعد كل
هدف فلعيبه منتخب السامبا وبعد كل جول
سجلوه كانوا بيتجمعوا وبيرقصوا ومش هم بس
حتى مدربهم راس معهم كمان بعد الهدف
الثالث ورقص او رقص اللاعبين كان تقدر
تقولوا ماده اساسيه لانكت ومقاطع وتويتات
ضحكت وعلقت كمان على راس البرازيل
وبابا زعم وشعب
[موسيقى]
ولا كوبر
قدامهم خفيف الجماعه بصراحه بس خلينا نقول
انه مش الكل كان عنده نفس رده الفعل هذه
على موضوع رقص لاعبين البرازيل بعد
الاهداف اللاعب الايرلندي اسطوره مانشستر
يونايتد السابق
وفي تحليله وتعليقه على المباراه اعتبر
انه رقص البرازيليين بعد كل هدف هو
الاحترام للخصم ومعجبه طبعا وخصوصا لما
المدرب كمان رقص معهم ول يعني بنفهم الرقص
بعد اول هدف بس مش بعد كل هدف يعني لازم
يرقصوا وهذا الراي ما كان رايه بس على
فكره كثير ناس سيده وشافوا الموضوع انه
بالفعل قله احترام لدرجه انه مدرب
البرازيل طلع وبرر في المؤتمر الصحفي وقال
انه ما قدر يقاوم وما يرقص وانه المنتخب
لعيبته شباب ولازم هو يجاري روحهم روح
الشباب هاي وانهم كانوا قالوا له انه راسك
معنا بعد كل جول وقال انه ايضا ابدا
الموضوع ما في الا تحت بالعكس هو بيكون
بكن كل الاحترام لمنتخب كوريا ومدربهم
كمان وما بين هذا الرئيس وهذاك الراي
الناس بالفعل منصمه
واحنا في تفاعلكم حبينا نعرف ارائكم انتم
مشاهدينا وسالناكم انتم مع اي وجهه نظر
واجاباتكم جاءت على النحو التالي الاغلبيه
ب 75% شايفين ان الموضوع احتفال عادي اما
الباقي لهن 25% فشايفين انه هو بالفعل قله
احترام للخصم
معنا الان المحلل الرياضيه حسن الدراز
اهلا بك استاذ حسن معنا استاذ حسن انت شو
رايك
هل هذا رئيس عن جد ولا الا الاحترام
اهلا بك راويه سعيد ما انا بتواجد معك في
اول مره
بصراحه بصراحه
المهم المنتخب السامبا اصلا
فالموضوع مش جديد والهجوم مش جديد لان
احنا لو رجعنا بدايه الموسم كان فيه برده
هجوم على واحد من اهم نجوم المنتخب
البرازيلي اللي هو فينيسيوس جونيور ان هو
بيرقص بعد كل الهدف ان هو بيحتفل بعد كل
هدف ويتعرض كبير جدا في اسبانيا لغايه لما
كل اللاعبين برازيليين حول العالم حركات
[موسيقى]
او اشارات معينه لا احد من عائلتها اذا
كان جايب بيبي صغير بيصير مثلا يعمل هيك
شفناها كثير في في الملاعب ولكن هل في
مبالغه لانه بعد كل هدف راسه مطوله مع
المدرب ولا لانه كاس العالم هذا شيء عادي
يعني كانه الناس شويه بلغوا بالانتقاد
واعتباره انه همم احترام
يعني
كويس او حتى تخرج فيها النسخه 2014 اللي
كانت موجوده
في المساله
لكن النقطه الاساسيه عايز اتكلم عنها كمان
ان احنا تكلمنا في مصر شعبي لكن النصف
الثاني مين اللي بيواجه اللي بيوجد التوام
اهوت بروتين بروتين دائما لاعب هو لاعب
ايرلندي لاعب قوي لاعب ما بيحبش الاحتيا
ثلاث ما بيحبش اللي بيكون في مشاعر كره
القدم
اكثر من لاعب في السنوات الماضيه ان هم ما
ينفعش يسلم على زميله حتى
الموادي الى ملعب المباراه هو نوع الالعاب
كثير جد يعني ما عندهوش همم
بعض من اللاعيبه الانجليزي عندهم ال- ال-
خلاص زميلك اللي كان بيلعب معك كده
التاريخ الثاني خلاص ما ينفعش تسلم
هزار ما فيهاش الود
المبالغ فيه من وجهه نظر
ههه اي منتخب
فريق من ثقافه البلد
بنلاقي في تركيا اكثر وشعوب عقلانيه اكثر
قد ايه هذا يعكز في مباريات كره القدم
سواء بالاحتفال او حتى في الحزن لما
يخسروا ويدخل يعني بجولهم اهداف
الاحتفال بشكل عام في اي هدف او في اي
بطوله هو جزء من ثقافه البني ادم يعني
مثلا لو احنا جئنا بصينا مثلا مغربي
هتلاقي ان مثلا كده عيب بيحتفل
شعبه بطريقه معينه باسلوب مثلا التحيه
معينه بالشكل المعين اللي بيعمله بعض
اللاعبين العرب واللعابات في كاس العالم
زي ما احنا شفنا حتى اللعيبه السعوديين
سالم الدوسري ليه احتفال معين عمله
[موسيقى]
او شخصيه اللاعب بتصير
كان بيبوس اخته فكل لاعب اللحظه
الانتصار هدف دائما بتحمل جزء من شخصيته
ايه كانها الانسان بتاعته
بعد كل هدف
لكل ثقافته وشخصيته نشكرك جزيلا شكرا
لمحلل الرياضيه حسن دراز
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد من اول ما بدات كورونا
واحنا بنغطي معكم خسائر العالم الناجمه عن
الجارحه قطاع الطيران كان واحد من اكثر
القطاعات اللي بالفعل الضررات ان لم يكن
ربما لكن اليوم الاتحاد الدولي للنقل
الجويتا اعلن ان الوضع عم بيتغير الحمد
لله واخيرا ومن السنه الجاي قطاع الطيران
راح يعود للربحيه ولاول مره من عام 2019
يعني وكانه بالعربي الفصيح بنقول انه قطاع
الطيران تعافى واخيرا من كورانا هذا
القطاع اللي تدمر حقيقه يعني طيران حول
العالم توقف لمده شهور ولا في الرحلات او
الافرحلات تم الغاءها وتغيرات جذريه كمان
تم ادخالها في اجراءات السفر هذا غير
الخسائر اللي اجبرك شركات الطيران كثير
انها تقيل موظفين يعني معاناه بالفعل
حقيقي هذا كله كان سبب في نقص في التذاكر
مؤخرا واسعار زياده او عاليه جدا وبشكل
غير طبيعي حتى
السياحه طلع فيها ظاهره اسمها السياحه
الانتقاميه وهي هبت الناس للسفر بعض
كورونا واللي كلنا ربما عشناها واللي خلت
اسعار التذاكر الطيران تطلع وتصير غاليه
جدا وفي وقت الاتحاد الدولي بيقول الشركات
هترجع تربح في طيارين معترضين وبيقولوا لا
الشركات يا دوب بدات تتنفس شويه في
الارباح في 2019 تجاوزت 26 مليار لكن الان
الاتحاد الدولي متوقع ارباح ما بتجاوز
الخمس مليارات في عام 2023 لكن السؤال
للابرز اللي بدنا نطرحه اليوم همم كل هذا
كيف راح ياثر علينا احنا كمسافرين طبعا
راح نناقش هذا الموضوع مع ضيفنا من
القاهره الكابتن محمود القط القط التيار
وخبير السلامه الجويه اهلا بك كابتن معنا
همم كابتن احنا كيف راح نتاثر هل هذا شيء
راح يكون منيح لانه نتوقع بما فيه طلب
كثير الاس لسه راح تزداد اكثر وراح نبطل
نسافر لانه راح تصير غالي كثير
مساء الخير على حضرتك وعلى الساده
المشاهدين يعني خلينا نشوف الموضوع بنظره
تفاؤليه ان شاء الله لا يعني ما يبقاش
التاثير سلبي ولكن يكون ايجابي على السفر
هو في بصراحه حاجتين يعني حاجه ايجابيه
وحاجه سلبيه الحاجه الايجابيه ان اا
شايفين نشاط ملحوظ في الطيران المدني في
اقبال كبير من شركات الطيران على شراء
طيران في عوده لانشاء شركات جديده بشكل
جديد لما بعد كرونا وهو الشركات المنخفضه
التكاليف او الطائرات همم المنخفضه
التكاليف همم
يؤدي ان هيكون
بالضبط تشارترفلايس ولكن هي الجديد فيها
ان هي ما كانتش منتشره في منطقه الشرق
الاوسط والعالم العربي ولكن حاليا بنشوف
بعض الدول بتسعى ان هي تنشئ شركات وباعداد
طائرات ضخمه 70 هنا بعض الدول هتنشئ شركات
بحوالي اكثر من 500 طياره وده رقم ضخم جدا
في علامه شرطه كمان هيخلي وتيره الطيران
اسرع وهيخلي المرونه في المواعيد والمرونه
في الاسعار هتكون اسرع لكن خلينا ناكد ان
في تحدي ثاني مهم جدا بيواجه كل شركات
الطيران القائمه او اللي هتنشر وهو الحرب
طبعا الروسيه الاوكرانيه لان اسعار الوقود
غير مستقره بالمره احنا في عام 1000 اللي
هو عام 2022 شفنا سعر البرميل الوقود 120$
وحاليا بيتجاوز ال 90 دولار وده سعر بيخلي
شركات الطيران دائما تبقى عندها مشكله في
السياسه السعريه التحدي الثاني والمهم
اللي ناس كثير ما بتاخذش بالها منه هو
تحدي التصنيع الخاص بقطع غيار الطائرات
نفسها لان
اولا في مشكله عندنا في الشحن المشكله
الثانيه ان في مصانع موجوده اصلا في منطقه
الحرب او منطقه النزاع
ومؤثره على تصنيع السيارات على العديد من
القطع الغيارات ان هم نتوقع انه الاسعار
تصير احسن حتى لو رجع انتعاش هذا القطاع
لغايه ما تخلص الحرب يعني ما راح تعيشوا
ما راح يعيشوا هذا القطاع عم بيعيشه
العالم كله من ناحيه اقتصاديه يعني
التضخم هائل هو هو الحقيقه نعم هو الحقيقه
ان الطيران اقتصاد هش زي ما بيتقال عليه
بيتاثر باي حاجه من العوامل المحيطه دي زي
ما حضرتك اشارتي في الاول وبقرونه يعني
فعلا ضمه صناعه الطيران حضرتك قلتيها بلفظ
يعني انسب لفظ ممكن يتقال والحرب الحاليه
هي فعلا مؤثر سلبي على هذه الصناعه خصوصا
ان يعني الحرب جايه بعد وباء كورونا وعايز
اقول لحضرتك على حاجه مهمه بس في نفس
الوقت في نظره تفاؤليه للامر لان حياه
نفسها في 2020 كان توقعاتها نتعاف الطيران
لن يكون قبل 2025 او 26 حاليا بنتكلم من
وفي في شيء اخر ايجابي كان في خبر اليوم
بيتحدث عن انه همم يعني مرتبات الطيارين
ارتفعت بشكل هائل فعلى الاقل طيارين راح
يكونوا سعيدين ومبسوطين خلال 2023 ههه
شكرا ههه
يعني الاقبال على الطلب للطيارين بقى اكتر
كمان وتحولنا من من زياده في الطيارين الى
حجز في الطيارين مره اخرى 2019
جزيلا لك من القاهره الكابتن محمود القطه
الطيار وخدير السلام على الجويه شكرا
في مقطع فيديو منتشر ومتداول بشكل كبير
على المنصات وعمل حاله من الضجه والغضب
الواسع في مصر خلونا نشوفه مع بعض
[موسيقى]
الفيديو على فكره اطول من هيك بكتير بس ما
حبينا نعرض منه اكثر من هاي الثواني
القليله وما عندي شارع المقطع انتشرت
الروايه الصادمه الحقيقه اللي بتقول انه
المصور واللي بيتصور هم ممرضين في وحده
للرعايه حديثه الولاده في المنيا وانه
الفيديو هذا عباره عن رهان بينهم لمين
بيقدر يركب ابره كانيولا للرضيع وهو معصوب
العينين
يعني بصراحه استهتار ولامه ولا شيء غير
اخلاقي و كارثه بكل المقاييس هاي كانت
تعليقات بصراحه المصريين وغير المصريين
على هذا المقطع ولكن الغضب والاستنكار او
بعد الغضب والاستنكار تحركت الجهات
الرسميه نقابه التمريض في المحافظه كشفت
مفاجاه بتخلي القصه لسه صادمه اكثر
انا علمت بيها يوم الخميس ده طبعا
للمصداقيه اتبعتت ليه من احد
الاكونتات على الماسنجر حد بيسالني سؤال
بيقول لي ايه رايك لو ممرض او شخص بيركب
كانولا وهو مغمض عينه
وداخل في تحدي مع حد ثاني بمناسبه الفيديو
اللي حضرتك بتتكلم عليه بقول لحضرتك ده مش
ممرض ولا ليه اي علاقه بالتمريض ولا نقابه
التمريض وغير مقيد بجداره النقابه وغير
مقيد بسجلات النقابه وغير مرخص لان
المفروض ان الممرض همم لما بيتخرج من خلال
الاماكن الحكوميه وبيجيء عندي هنا في
النقابه
تخيلوه انه طلع حتى مش ممرض عموما يعني
وزاره الداخليه كشفت المزيد من التفاصيل
ببيان نزلت امبارح واعلنت في ضبط الشخصين
اللي ظهروا في المقطع اللي بيصور واللي
بيحن الطفل وقالت انه الشاب اللي بيركب
الكانيلا هو مساعد ممرض في حضانه تتبع
لجمعيه خاصه وانه اللي معه بالفيديو طالب
بمعهد التمريض وبيشتغل في نفس الحضانه و
الاثنين اعترفوا انهم عملوا الفيديو
لقيتهار مهاره الاول في العمل وتعليم
ممرضين اخرين والبيان اكد بيان الداخليه
اكد انه جاري اتخذ الاجراءات اللازمه
بحقهم اما بالنسبه للمركز الصحي بحسب بيان
لمحافظ المنيا فتقرر اغلاق قيام من سماه
البيان احد العاملين فيه من منتحيلي مهنت
التمريض بعمل يهدد حياته احد الاطفال
واضاف البيان كمان انه اصلا المعاينه بينت
انه المركز في مخالفات عديده مثل اداره
منشئه طبيه بعماره سكنيه وممارسه افراد
مهنه التمريض بدون ترخيص
كمان وجود معمل تحاليل غير مرخص وجود
حضانات حضانات اكثر من المرخص له سوء ايضا
تخزين ادويه كمان
في حلقه امبارح استعرضنا سواء ابرز كلمات
وعبارات سيطرت على الاخبار هذه السنه
واليوم وما اقتربنا من نهايه العام خلونا
نستعرض سوا مجموعه من الارقام القياسيه
اللي سجلت في 2022 اولها طبعا واللي ما في
حدا مش ملاحظ طبعا اللي كمان ما في حدا
بالعالم مش متاثر فيه كمان هو التضخم
وارتفاع الاسعار الجنوني والصاروخي في
العالم وخصوصا في اسعار المواد الغذائيه
واللي طبعا من اسباب الرئيسيه كانت الحرب
لوكرانيه الروسيه اما الرقم القياسي
الثاني فكان ايضا من النتائج الحرب
الروسيه الاوكرانيه وهو ارتفاع عدد
اللاجئين ست مليون طلع من اوكرانيا لا دول
الجوار وثمانيه مليون نزحوا في الداخل
الاوكراني لتتجاوز بذلك اعداد اللاجئين
على الصعيد العالمي حاجز ال 100 مليون
وهذا رقم قياسي سجل في عام 2022
ومن حرب روسيا واوكرانيا التغير المناخي
اول رقم قياسي هاي السنه في هذا المجال مش
غريب علينا طبعا وصلنا متعودين انه كل سنه
بنسمعه هو نفسه عم نحكي طبعا عن الصيف
الاكثر حراره ما بعرفش لامت لوين ممكن
يوصل يعني مع الحراره ولكن مع الحراره
العاليه طبعا زادت الحرائق مع العالم في
العالم والسنه كمان غطت اكثر من 600 الف
هكتار حول العالم عم نحكي عن سته الاف كم
مربع
صدفه
كوريا الشماليه وصواريخها كانت كمان من
الارقام القياسيه هاي السنه و تحديدا في
نوفمبر وتحديدا كمان لما اطلقت خلال 24
ساعه 23 صاروخ في بحر اليابان ردا على
اوسع مناورات جويه ما بين كوريا الجنوبيه
وامريكا ومن كوريا لبريطانيا وجنازه
الملكه اليزابيث ولا اعداد من حضروا فيها
للقاء نظره الوداع الاخيره عليها في كنيسه
وسمر بحيث انه هذه الارقام تجاوزت 250,000
شخص وهذا رقم قياسي اخر هذه السنه
[موسيقى]
ومتى ما تصدر العناوين والاخبار طوال هذه
السنه ومكمل كمان الى الماسك اله نصيب من
الارقام القياسيه لاكثر من سبب الاول انه
هو الاغنى في العالم والثاني بسبب صفقه
تويتر اللي بلغت قيمتها 44 مليار دولار
وثالث هو سلسله الاقالات اللي شغل فيها
العالم وغيرها وغيرها طبعا عفوا من
القرارات والتحركات غير المسبوقه اما على
الصعيد الفني همم مجموعه فنيه كان بيملكه
الراحل اعلن احد مؤسسي مايكروسوفت حققت
رقم قياسي لما ب- لما بيعت في مزاد مقابل
مليار و620
فنيا كمان النجمه تايلور سويفت صدرت
الارقام القياسيه في جانبين واحد ايجابي
والثاني للاسف سلبي فاولا البومها مد
نايتس اللي حصل على رقم قياسي اكثر البوم
من سمع خلال يوم واحد عبر منفاي اما
السلبي فهو حصولها على لقب المشهوره
الاكثر تلويفا للبيئه والسبب طبعا رحلات
الجويه الكثيره في طائره الخاصه وفي عالم
الرياضه الاسباني حطم الرقم القياسي
بتحقيقه بطوله البرنس لاند 22 22 بيفوزوا
في فرنسا المفتوحه والبرنسلام هي البطولات
الاربعه الكبرى في التنس واخيرا الارقام
اهم الارقام القياسيه في 2022 كان ببساطه
الثمن الثمانيه مليار وهو تعداد سكان
العالم اللي تجوزوا هاي العتبه الشهر
الماضي
شكرا لكم والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]